foreign
Dallas Texas what's up Katie
hi there what's up
oh just anxious don't be anxious this is
the anti-anxiety show
that's why I'm calling so what's up
what's up
so my question is
how do I get over the fear slash anxiety
of my husband dying
so my husband's perfectly healthy like
there's nothing wrong with him so it
sounds ridiculous for me to ask that
don't start out judging yourself we
haven't even gotten going yet
100 chip a hundred percent chance
at some point your husband dies
right right
this is the statement that's a fact
there's a period at the end of that
sentence it happens at some point
so you're not crazy
okay okay your alarm systems may be
going off they may be detecting things
whatever but you're not crazy okay your
body's just trying to take care of you
so tell me more
um my husband and I first started dating
we were about
22 and 24 and he told me hey I think I'm
gonna die at 25. I just have this
feeling I've had this feeling my whole
life so we turned 25 I was like
panicking and then of course he's fine
we're 30 and 31 now but at dinner the
other night I asked him I was like hey
what's your goals for life you know mine
was like to write a book and to maybe
have kids and so I was expecting
something like start a business or
something
and he told me he was like I'm gonna die
young
and I was like well what and he was like
I'm gonna die young I think about 60.
and it just immediately set off like all
this anxiety like I'm gonna have to
be alone I'm not going to be safe my
kids are only going to have you know a
father till he's 60 that's so young and
like
just started feeling anxious about every
time around my husband I'm like is this
you know the last moment we're gonna be
together like just these outrageous like
thoughts coming in have you lost
somebody did your dad pass away
um no but
wow I don't know why that's triggering
an emotion um I don't have a good
relationship with my father okay
um he did adopt me okay and then my
biological father was completely absent
okay
so your body knows that story right
yeah
that the man that's signed up to take
care of you
leaves
yeah yeah
it knows that in the mitochondria it
knows that all the way down to the Core
right
I told you at the beginning this call
you're not crazy
okay
now your husband
his death projections are they're
avoiding strategies
for the hard terrifying work that every
person has to go through which is how do
I make a good life
and it's easier just to be like well I'm
gonna die anyway
to avoid the what if I did start a
business yeah what if it fails
what if I did have three kids yeah one
of them got sick what if I wasn't a good
dad what if they just annoy me and they
spend all my money
I'll just do nothing
it's just it's an anxiety response it's
a depression response right
that makes 100 sense I never thought of
that but that makes attract he is
um it happened to me the other night the
Astros were playing
and I caught myself after the sixth or
seventh time in the playoffs
um with my little son with my son was
watching it together and we're cheering
him on and somebody would get out or
they'd make an error
and I would say uh that's it I don't
like it that's it
next guy's gonna hit get a hit I didn't
know more know the next guy was gonna
get a hit you know what I was doing I
was subconsciously projecting I was
practicing the next guy in line hitting
a home run and the Astros losing
I was practicing it the great Amos
taverski is a psychologist uh he's just
one of the smartest men to ever live he
said being pessimistic is stupid because
if it comes through you've experienced
it twice once when you thought about it
once what actually happens what a dumb
way to live
you know what I mean and so your husband
is like well I'm gonna avoid failure I'm
gonna avoid the hard tasks of leaning in
what he's got clearly got some stuff
that happened to him when he was a kid
that made him think very short turn had
very short-term thinking right the
difference between abundance thinking
and a poverty mindset right all I have
to say is this
sometimes the question what are your
life goals is terrifying if somebody's
never seen that play out
that's a terrifying question it's big
some big failures so it makes sense
there you go like why he would feel that
way yeah dude I've tried man I got in
the ring I got knocked out I got
embarrassed I got hit so hard I peed my
pants I'm not getting back in there
right
yeah and then he's like almost
hoping the world takes him in four or
five years
because it just feels like it would be
better than just hurting all the time
and now he's been with you for several
years and you're great
so he doesn't want to just disappear
because you're awesome but 60 is fine
I'll start when I start getting old and
it takes longer to pee and that hurts
when I stand up right you know what I
mean yeah he's just doing the math
and the question what are your life
goals I remember the the first title I
wanted to like the book on your past
change of future I wanted to name it how
to change everything
and I was all excited about that title
and I told my wife and she goes I would
never read that book it's too much
I can't change everything and I was like
well you can just change it all and
she's like that's too much
because I got two little kids I can't
change that I'm married to you I can't
change that we live here like right so
all that to say is this
I would break these questions up into
smaller digestible chunks
where do you want to live
where do you want to live
let's just make like a plan where do you
want to live would you read a book with
me
and then I'll read the next one and you
read the next one I don't read books I
know let's just would you just do it for
me
we'll go on a wild romantic Rendezvous
after we finish every book how about
that right whatever the thing is
yeah
um
would you like how much sex do you want
to have this year this month this week
would you plan that with me
right so we're taking what this what are
your goals what's this life gonna look
like and we're just breaking up into
smaller chunks and here's what we're
doing now what are our goals we're
answering the question who do we want to
be
who do we want to be
what kind of non-anxious Life do we want
to build for ourselves and then what do
we got to do I think that's more what I
was looking
it was and the questions what are your
life goals instantly set off dude I'm
not I don't want to be here
all right you didn't even answer your
question
um and then here's an important thing as
his wife you get to say I don't accept
that
I reject that
you married me you don't get the cash
out at 60.
yeah
because that's just when it starts
getting weird and I get super wrinkly
you gotta write it we if I if you're
taking all my pretty years you got to
ride out my last 30. right and you'll
still be beautiful in the last 32 by the
way so
um
like he can run his mouth about dying in
30 years cool but in the meantime you
want to partner with him on creating a
life worth living with the time you got
left
right
will not do anything
yep that's your anxiety talking
yeah right that's the fighter fighter
freeze like what we can't fight this guy
I can't run from it so I'm just gonna
shove it all down
all right
I'm just gonna sit on it and if you sit
on it long enough
if you compress it all down another word
for compress you know if you push your
hands down it's too depress right
and your body just says this is this
let's just don't move this is safe no
one will see us we can ride this thing
out and then we're done
and
as for me Katie I'm not interested in
that kind of life
me either right so two two important
takeaways here the next time your body
takes off on you
don't start with I should have or I've
got to
just be curious what's my body trying to
tell me right now what's it scared of
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh another man says he's gonna leave me
and then you look at him and be like
I you don't get to
right the other two did you don't get to
or maybe maybe the next time it's you
catch him glancing some way and it makes
you feel small or he says he doesn't
want to have sex one night and you
suddenly feel your body just starts and
like is he what am I being curious what
what I'm assuming curious what is my
body trying to tell me oh I don't like I
just I took that as rejection
maybe it has nothing to do with right
you start start being curious about what
your body's trying to tell you your
body's a pretty good uh signal signal
Giver if we can listen to it
the second thing is
is
um be direct with them
you promised me
you told God and our family and all of
our friends
that you're in this with me
if you die when you're 60 you die and
you're 60 but until we get there you and
I want us to build a life worth living
what is that going to look like
where we want to live what do we want to
do how much sex we want to have do you
want to have kids we not want to have
kids like what do we want that to look
like
if you die when you're 60 we'll deal
with that when you're 60.
that's not an excuse to cash out for the
next 30 Years
and he may need to go talk to a
counselor in fact I think it'd probably
be wise
I wish you would I I've been trying have
you gone
yes
have you invited him to your session
uh
no give that a shot I have mentioned it
to him nope you've passively been like
well it's helping me maybe it would help
you that's not it you're right it's not
it say it would mean the world to me if
you came to my next counseling session
with me I ain't going to that that's
dumb I think you could think it's done
all you want you get to do that but I'm
asking you as your wife for me would you
go
because I'm trying to learn some
different ways to love you better and it
would help if you were there
and that's that sister's taking a risk
right
right yeah
he's lucky to have you
and your biological dead didn't leave
because of you
and that man who adopted you I'm so glad
he saw you and you were young and said I
won't take her home
and whatever's got sideways in y'all's
relationship isn't on you he's your dad
right
right
okay
it's a high honor in my day that I got
to meet you and talk to you
thank you I appreciate you taking the
time to talk with me I want you from
this call forward to start being nicer
to Katie because you're mean to Katie
quit being mean to Katie
you've had enough mean in your life it
would be nice is that fair
it is fair 100 all right being mean is
how am I gonna deal with this moment
right now
being kind is what might next week or
next month or next year look like and
what can I do now to get there
mean is short-term thinking
kind is tomorrow thinking
mean is I could beat you today at the
polls
kind thinking is man what kind of world
are our kids about to inherit 10 years
from now
mean is you're an idiot kind is
I'm sorry here you go ahead of me
is Katie why did you do that again
you're just gonna make you met
kind is hey honey
let's build a life worth living
you promised me you would
you're in I'm in
I won't ask you what your goals are
anymore but I am going to ask how much
sex you want to have I'm gonna ask you
where you want to eat for dinner
I'm gonna ask you where do you want to
live we're going to figure those things
out
build a life worth living